welcome to this video playing em western
em western no name okay it's playing a
b3 setup yeah pre moving here wouldn't
be good so how do i check it yeah that's
somewhat unconventional I wonder how he
is going to set up now yeah something
completely free stylish Quint down okay
maybe I can operate with Quincy five
getting the Queen traded or pushed back
okay so Quincy five is going to play
Queen h4 I guess a Quincy five is a
weird move anyway well maybe just
prepare a long canceling I don't think
if he cancels long I can do this Queen a
three night before thing which is
irritating for sure I wonder if I have
some ideas to open up the position like
f five tags on I can also go rook G ATM
flicking this in that's probably not a
bad idea g3 f5 okay okay I'm not
thinking about this long now I want to
open up the position this this must be
okay for me the the bishop on g7 will
open up if he takes and comfort concrete
measures I have the check and 94 coming
looks that looks aggressive at least
let's do that or is it failing due due
to some direct move like night a four or
something I have Queen d6 now
maybe Bishop v4 94 I can take h5 now
right f5 I'm sorry and then 96 check
okay and that's not even a totally clear
position I kind of like the idea to SEC
the Queen huh it looks here this looks
interesting I can well I'm doing that
it's a bit crazy to do but it is an
interesting way to play ok I saw that
but I thought that my bishops in
connection with the idea look H sick g6
to h6 this is not clear I mean I know
between humans this is an interesting
way to play I just have two minor pieces
but his piece set up it's not really
harmonious the Queen especially here
maybe he finds some direct refutation of
course it's it's possible but it it's
not looking easy so Bishop c5 now not
sure
or up g 6
rook g6 I start with that I'd start with
that
it's not so not sure if I'm threatening
something directly really just feels
very very tricky to play mmm ship c5 is
definitely a move I should consider okay
now now I cannot do it I can take let's
just take and play will create and now
Luke g1 is directly losing you to look
oh look age six and that's it right I
look at five no is playing look at 5i
that's a good defense that's a good
defense and okay so this is this I
cannot do
hmm do I get how do i get to his King
hmm it feels like I should have a win
I'd really feels like it but I don't see
it hey okay let's let's do this and go
from there I do I don't see you in oak
aged six look at five for the good good
defense if it goes taking it bow
yeah i would like to play root g 6 h-6
year quite obviously but root g 7
assists and then he has got this check
ok maybe this is far too slow i don't
know but just one minute left
something like Age 3 might be possible
probably I'm overlooking simple wins the
whole time it's really that's totally
possible yeah here I'm definitely not
having a tactical win anymore
time or still have have pressure here
but I'm definitely not to check meeting
him or anything
see I don't really see SSS anyway 44
made him I can always check the Queen
here for some harassment value but it's
not any way forward
i hoped i can take but i cannot write
it's not not leading to anything god
damn it and it's got to be five know
what was I thinking come on this is
frustrating Jack really frustrating this
was clearly a good sacrifice and then
I'm screwing this up check really
frustrating back yeah come on I'm
resigning yeah computer now can we can
show me how I could win this or at least
draw it I mean this is I know that it's
this is probably not objectively great
but it was very interesting and and here
there is the first wynia with roo gage
six okay rogue age six and that's it but
this is not very easy to see if Bishop
e7 now for the Queen trap okay no I took
but but but even here I absolutely not
believing that that there should be
worse okay the compass on equal not with
this but with them with Ruby mc4 up
chief five
yeah I played I played some some very
very stupid museum quite obviously I was
thinking he cannot take for some reason
but I mean I was playing for win all the
time yeah i mean i can i can i can do
all kinds of drawers yeah like this
check check this is a dryer just a
perpetual but i wanted to win of course
which is probably probably there is no
win this is the whole problem
yeah so am Bishop g2 wins yeah just some
syntactic but I'm technically such an
idiot sometimes I mean this is just also
just winning now and check and then
that's it check now winning is a bit
strong I mean the computer gives it as
winning but this is nothing that that is
so easily done with no time but I have
good coordination and everything's
nicely protected yeah it was just
terribly disappointing I you have an
interesting idea and then then it feels
like that I mean I played some some
really atrocious moves here really
without any any great idea yeah wow yeah
tough game thanks for watching